I looked at the right and found these programs to help my brain. Yes, balancing parasympathetic, sympathetic, actually that's program I ran. I created.
I am missing anything, anxiety, anxiety, relaxation, brain wave, correction, brain beta.
Don't do the brain beta.
The brain beta would be somebody who would be for somebody who.
I don't even like that program because the idea is that somebody who's got completely, completely, uh, burdened owner Doritos.
So then the person that just can't even get off the couch literally can't get off the couch.
They have such extreme fatigue.
But typically it has nothing to do with their brain waves.
The person that's got complete fatigue and is sitting on the couch, probably watching television at all the time.
They're getting beta wave stimulation constantly. So it's really not a brain wave issue.
But certainly, when you talk about the four different brain waves and how they.
Most commonly affect a person's daily function. It really has to do with sleep relaxation, anxiety.
Those are the biggest things because the person can't get into an alpha theta state.
You have to get into alpha theta state in order to fall asleep in order to get good sleep and stay asleep.
When your brain is running at a higher theta beta wave, then you're not you're not going to get good sleep.
Now, you're going to have times of sleep that you will that you'll be in a beta state.
And those those are going to be your REM sleep states.
And I know there's a lot of things written about REM sleep.
You have to get your REM sleep in order to get really relaxation.
Really, it's the alpha sleep that is really going to bring you rest.
REM sleep keeps your brain alive. It keeps your brain active and it's healthy for your brain.
But it's not giving you rest.
So getting your brain down to that that that those lower brain waves is important.
And that's why you if a person is having issues with its relaxation and sleep and anxiety.
The struggle is a lot of those people are working at a job that they have to be in front of a computer all day.
We said there are computer screens that you could buy.
I'm sure there are Amazon that fix to your screen itself that will block some of those waves.
There's computer glasses that we sell in our store that are beta wave blocking glasses.
There's like little sunglasses, but they block beta waves.
Those are good to use for screen time. Those are good for your kids to use for screen time.
When our kids were smaller, we use those glasses.
We have several pair of the house that we've used for screen time.
They don't use them anymore. Most all our kids.
Limit their children's screen time.
Every nose, Dr. Mallory who works for us and Dustin.
Dr. Mallory's my daughter.
None of their kids. Their oldest child is 15.
They have six kids. None of them have cell phones.
And they live. They don't have a TV that's blaring all the time.
Like like somebody households have.
They don't watch television hardly at all.
The kids. They're hardly ever on screens. They're out playing.
They read their kids to remind me of what I was a kid, I'd ever watched tv.
We only had three channels there worked.
And, and I had to be the one standing behind holding the antenna.
Okay. That's the youngest son.
So it.
You know, our society has changed a lot.
So if you.
One of things you want to do to call the brain.
This is one of the things you want to do to call me your brain.
That's just from a frequency standpoint.
There's all sorts of different things from a chemistry standpoint.
From a chemistry standpoint, with anxiety, you're dealing with glutamate, so glutamate
is a neurotransmitter that's an excitatory neurotransmitter that's most commonly associated with anxiety
and OCD issues.
So glutamate is made in your body and you need glutamate.
But excess glutamate causes more OCD, more anxiety, more inner angst, more inner focus,
more inner drive.
So most very successful people have a lot of glutamate, a lot of glutamate, but excess can cause
anxiety.
They're not those same people aren't necessarily the happiest people and not the most relaxed
people.
So a balance of removing it as many glutamates as possible.
That's why bad glutamates like modusodium glutamate still function as a glutamate receptor carrier
stimulator, neurotransmitter that fires excitatory brainwaves and can actually burn out neurons.
And people that have, some people are prone to that because they have gene defects on their
glutamate, glutamate gene, so they produce excess glutamate and they just have to work at
cleaning up their diet as much as possible.
Any inflammation in the gut is going to cause inflammation in the brain, inflammation in
the brain is going to cause excitation and worsening in the person's condition.
I get a good video to watch about that is the video that I created a couple of years ago
on neuroinflammation and microglial driving.
If you search our blog, neuroinflammation, it's on multiple of the different courses as
well.
You'll see that video.
It's going to have our video very important to watch.
So flavonoids help decrease that inflammation of the brain as well.
So all right, hopefully that helps.
I sleep well, especially after I started taking high-dose melatonin.
I know it's not at an accident at that level, but I notice sleepy, deeper anyhow.
Sometimes I wake up at 5 or 6 a.m. with my heart racing a bit.
Did you say you developed a rife program for parasympathetic, sympathetic, and I don't
mention about it?
Yes, I did develop a rife program for parasympathetic.
Let me look that up and I can send that to you on a flash drive too.